donc on va passer au comparatif des
tôles je sais que vous la trouvez vous
ça les cas il ya 14 car bien sûr tous
les soirs et un quotidien c'est à vous
cliquer avec mon ami mouloud et bien sûr
tpm pays et c'est vrai que ces quatre
salles quatre ambiances alors chez c'est
à vous il ya du budget leurs envoyés
spéciaux sont envoyés à hong kong les
duplex ont répété enregistré est monté
au millimètre regarder ça file droit
dans 7 à vous regarder au reporter
nelson getten stéphane latour sont sur
place il était ce week-end au coeur des
défis les défilés interdits
c'est ce qu'on appelle les fronts
kleiner c'est les manifestants les plus
radicaux qui sont devant les
manifestations
voilà alors voyez c'est à vous c'est
bien c'est prochaine chez quotidien on
envoie les journalistes en duplex à
l'autre bout du monde aussi l'accès et
au brésil justement alors forcément il
ya deux trois secondes de décalage
mais c'est normal ils sont au brésil
brésil ont peur au brésil dans l'état de
rondônia baptiste et en duplex baptiste
des montier salut baptiste salis gagnent
ça fait maintenant six jours qu'on est
ici en amazonie avec paul bouffard alors
voyez c'est bien et nous chez tp on en
voit un gars tu me met du studio en
plein paris dark ya un gros décalage et
ça donne ça regarde mon sort cyril et du
rythme
[Applaudissements]
temps forts de leur jeu en garde à vue
c'est rien
[Applaudissements]
bravo à chaque ça d'ailleurs chez c'est
à vous les questions des journalistes
sont en gris pertinente même un petit
peu poil à gratter rien vous consacre un
long passage à la sphère clearstream
est ce que vous diriez la même chose de
vos ennuis d'aujourd'hui je pense aux
deux peut-être plus gros c'est que vous
devriez subir dans les mois à venir pour
vous oui ou va j'aime beaucoup patrick
un cauet mois là moi j'ai frère je suis
avec trois dictionnaires genre à cracher
le bled le biche light show sur canal+
dont clic même quand on parle de sport
frère on a des questions hyper sérieux
se passait assez carré c'est vous c'est
mon but c'est mon boulot de regarde car
lewis on voit que cet athlète utilise le
sport pour sortir du silence
est ce que vous le sport vous a fait
permettre vous a permis de dire des
choses de communiquer des choses et
dompter pmp ya des questions éthiques là
tout de suite c'est franchement c'est
des questions tout aussi intéressante
mais beaucoup plus facile d'accès et
regardez combien possède un joujou qui
fait des guili guili sexy
stern et goûtent qu'elle ragga et puis
l'un des chroniqueurs dans les trois
divisions comme je vous le dis tous les
soirs chez quotidienne et chroniqueur
prennent la parole pour dire des choses
vraiment quand ils prennent la parole
sait on sait que les gars ils ont bossé
toute la journée ils viennent pas les
mains dans les poches qui savent que ça
va faire mouche
regardez comme pour annoncer le décès
d'un célèbre photographe de mode c'est
carré c'est fort asine tu voulais rendre
un hommage
oui je parlais d'une légende de la photo
l'un des plus grands photographes de
l'histoire qui vient de s'éteindre
peter lindbergh et j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer lindbergh et l'interview il
ya trois ans voilà dans 7 à vous les
chroniqueurs commence un peu à ce lâcher
ils font même des petites blagues
pendant les recettes de cuisine saïda et
solutions mutation packard bell ce soir
ses merguez et vous savez que ma mère
m'a toujours dit le jour où tu feras
manger une merguez un ancien président
de la république ni saveur et chef avec
nicolas sarkozy ne mange pas avec nous
ce soir
bon c'est pas grave et plus dans tpm
paix quand un chroniqueur demande la
parole ont jusque là on va vraiment
faire avancer le débat
on va apprendre des choses intéressantes
qui touche les français qui vous touche
regardez j'étais dans les gorges du
verdon je faisais du canoë je me suis
retourné je suis tombé dans l'eau il
peut attirer les brèches et arrivées nez
à nez avec smith boom non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]